that's the best part about Los Angeles
it's filled with all these like Don
Quixote type characters you know people
who have come from everyone's left their
families their homes their friends their
jobs to pursue a dream where they know
that the percentage of them achieving
that dream is never and they do it
anyway you know you're lucky to get an
audition then you get it you get there
you walk into a room full of guys that
look just like you you realize you're
not the only one that wore the cowboy
hat then you can hear the other guy in
the other room auditioning and now
you're thinking about not doing it like
him as opposed to doing it the way that
you wanted to do it
then before you go in you hear the
casting director negotiating the deal
for the guy that already got the part
yeah turns out Jared Leto already got it
yeah you know then you go in you think
you're doing it you just say I'll do it
as an acting exercise
I know I'm not going to get it I'll just
I'll stick it as an experience you know
you go to your car you got a parking
ticket
because the street cleaning sign has
been covered by the auditions this way
sign